imagine you're on a beach
it's flat its wide with pristine sand
looks nice right unfortunately many
beaches don't look this way they're
narrow with steep cliffs and waves
breaking close to the property line this
is a beach that's experiencing erosion
in America about 80 to 90 percent of
sandy coastlines have this problem so
the government spends billions to expand
some of the most rapidly eroding beaches
in an effort to defend the coast but
this effort while effective in the short
term can actually hurt beaches in the
long run it's because every shoreline on
the planet is subject to erosion beach
erosion occurs when waves and currents
remove sand from the shoreline the loss
of sand makes the beach narrower and
lowers its elevation this erosion
becomes a problem when it reaches
structures built by humans along the
coast especially for beaches that
generate tourism the visitors enjoy the
sandy coasts while the city and towns
nearby enjoy the revenue gained but the
driving factor there is the beach a
place like Miami Beach wouldn't have the
same draw if there weren't lots of sand
in fact there's a time when it didn't
look this way at all in the 1970s a
seawall turned the beach Miami into a
narrow strip but by the 80s that Beach
had we emerged nice and wide how well
coastal engineers rebuilt it through a
process called beach nourishment
each nourishment is a short protection
strategy to try to counter the loss the
natural loss of sand the typical way to
do this is with dredging boats will dig
up sand from a borrow site and move it
on to the beach you'll have a big pipe
and pump suck up the sand then it's
transferred to the coastline or it's
dumped or pumped out onto the beach and
then bulldozers move it around to try to
mimic what the natural beach was like
before the project took place the result
is a nice wide beach the new profile
will better defend the property line
from damage during more intense weather
like storm surge flooding in the United
States beach nourishment is the main
strategy used to protect coastal
properties from risky erosion but
there's a problem
the protection doesn't last as the
constant beating of waves and wind takes
the sand away from the shore and it soon
looks like it did before the nourishment
occurred every to date years on average
the nourishments need to be repeated
like this speech in Florida well this
morning Lido Beach is under a local
state of emergency problem getting worse
by the hour Lido Beach on the Gulf Coast
of Florida got an emergency nourishment
in 2018 after damage from storms reduced
the beach to a narrow strip but the
beach had already gotten the new sand 15
times since 1964 and Lido key isn't an
outlier more than 200 of the 400 miles
of critical eroding coastlines in
Florida have received one or more
nourishments and across the United
States there have been nearly 3,000 no
nourishment events since 1923 the
funding for these projects gets a little
wonky but here's what's important the
federal government pays for a lot of
these nourishments up to 65 percent of
the cost state and local funds will make
up the rest
but not all beaches that want or need
nourishment will get it the Army Corps
of Engineers the group that approves
indesign's nourishments prioritizes
defending some beaches over others based
on the potential loss of value according
to ProPublica the Corps only funds
nourishments where the expected benefit
is two and a half times as high as the
cost poor communities won't often meet
that criteria so places like Miami Beach
Florida in Ocean City Maryland are more
likely to get a lot of nourishment they
have the expensive shore fund
developments that make the investment
worthwhile and for beaches that don't
make the cut for nourishment continued
erosion to lead to damaged or destroyed
property nourishments aren't just about
protecting buildings but also protecting
the economies tied to them in the beach
consider the 200 million dollars spent
on nourishments in Florida from 1995 to
2001 that might seem like a lot of money
until you see the revenue from coastal
tourism it was twenty one point six
billion in just one year 2001 on average
the state of Florida generates more than
five dollars of revenue for every dollar
invested beach nourishment which is why
nourishment is so appealing it makes
economic sense but they do present one
major problem according to research
published by the American Geophysical
Union there's a feedback loop
nourishment tends to happen along
beaches that generally have expansive
properties and they also seem to drive
development along the same Shores
despite the risk of future erosion if
you were in a place that had nursed its
beached the houses behind that project
were significantly larger in every case
then in a place that had never nourished
its its its shoreline at all research
found that areas with nourished beaches
had homes that were about three times
bigger than non nourished ones and the
success of development is a real problem
because it's based on false security
according to the researchers beach
nourishment may actually mask or reduce
the apparent impact of coastal hazards
without changing the natural processes
that drive them
in fact building more property in these
areas only increases the potential
damage from future erosion so while
beach nourishment protects properties
and local economies in the short run
they also trick us into thinking it's
safe to build in places that aren't
which sets up coastal communities for an
ugly reckoning at the shore sooner or
later
[Music]